brought to you by Dark Souls 3 pre-order
now to receive a free upgrade to the day
one edition hello friends and welcome to
reality check the show where gaming
meets science has this ever happened to
you
dark souls is a game that's well known
for its unwillingness to tell its
players well anything and let them
slowly but surely work their way through
a world of modeling NPCs badass boss
fights and endless boulders seriously
always with the boulders their games
that really don't believe in hand
holding earning them a reputation for
just being really bloody difficult so
you think that no one would play the
damn things and just put them back in
the cupboard where they belong and carry
on with their lives with a well I tried
attitude
but that's not so because have you seen
how dedicated the souls fanbases I mean
one guy even finished Dark Souls 1 using
bongos bongos which makes me feel even
worse about taking 10 plus tries on the
asylum demon so that got me thinking why
do some of us give up on difficult games
where others face the challenge head-on
well let's start with what makes a game
difficult if you think about it for
single-player games at least there's two
kinds of difficulty take what i like to
call inflated difficulty using mass
effect as an example a game that's
designed to hit a normal level of
difficulty and built with modifiers that
can increase or decrease certain
gameplay attributes to make things more
challenging for the player this is often
perceived by players as artificial
though it's no more artificial than
anything else in the game or shallow
because it usually doesn't rewrite enemy
behavior change any level design or make
any other changes that would be seen as
more complex typically enemies just get
more aggressive with their attack
patterns and gain more help then there's
designed difficulty where a game is damn
tricky but it was built that way from
the ground up dark souls is kind of the
perfect example of this everything is
taxing especially for newcomers from
combat and finding where you're supposed
to go to being punished by losing your
heart own souls when dying but it's not
unfair the game is designed this way
it's difficult but it's not a shallow
kind of difficult if the difficulty
level you choose overpowers your enemies
yet weakens you and reduces your
resources that can be perceived as
unfair but in the souls game it's hard
for me off but it's fair because you can
technically see every trap here every
enemy and workout every attack pattern
if you just take your time and play to
the game's rules the game is full of
trial and error and according to
researchers mark JP wolf and bernhard
pair on failure actually serves an
important purpose it makes us see games
in a completely different light you see
if we die by means of a certain trap or
a particular enemy when the checkpoint
reloads we're going to be paying closer
attention to our surroundings actively
looking for things that the game is
hiding to make sure we don't fall foul
at the same mistake we adjust our
perception of the game and force
ourselves to look for new strategies in
doing so we add more of an experience
for ourselves but why do games seesaw
between being hard and easy why do we
have to fail in order to win well wolf &
perrins research also showed that when
games are too easy players get bored
really bored like want to quit the game
after 20 minutes because they weren't
being challenged enough bored according
to the psychological theory of flow you
know when you're in the zone the game
needs to gradually increase in
difficulty over time but it has to
maintain a fine balance between being
too hard and too easy to keep players
interested a little bit of irregularity
is fun for the player but a steep
difficulty curve or no challenge at all
leads to disinterest so if you think
about it never failing can be just as
bad as never winning so failing can be a
good thing but why do we put ourselves
through the rage sadness and irritation
that comes with failure in the first
place it all boils down to admittedly
the quite childish human desire of
wanting what others don't have you may
have heard of conspicuous consumption no
not a Victorian disease but keeping up
with the Joneses you know the one where
someone buys fancy cars and designer
clothes over the cheaper everyday
alternative with the sole purpose of
showing everyone else just how well-off
they are turns out it sort of works the
same way with concept to the theory of
conceptual consumption coined by
behavioral economics and psychology
researchers dan airily and Michael
Norton is the belief that because of all
the advancements of Agriculture trading
and technology we don't spend all our
time hunting and gathering like our
ancestors did so we actively look for
new things to consume like ideas
information and concepts we're so
committed to consuming possessing and
experiencing things that we perceive as
rare a novel that will actually ignore
rational choices in order to do it so
case in point regardless of how
frustrated you get trying to do a one
bro run or how many controllers you
break striving for that illustrious
platinum trophy we attribute these
things as status symbol
in the same way we would attribute a
Ferrari with success so that may be one
of the reasons that you don't want to
give up on a challenging game because
the perceived social benefits will make
it all worth it in the end so there we
are a few thoughts and ideas about why
we play difficult games be sure to let
me know your thoughts do you stick with
difficult games or do you just steer
clear altogether let me know in the
comments box below I'll come find me on
Twitter i am at Lucy James games thanks
for watching this week's episode of
reality check and I'll see you next time